protesters including young children
gathered outside the annual convention
of the national rifle association in
texas on friday inside republican
leaders including former president trump
defended gun rights and denounced
stricter gun laws the convention is
being held in houston about 280 miles
from the site of today of tuesday's mass
shooting at an elementary school robert
costa is in houston bob good morning
good morning day one of the nra
convention it was a snapshot of many in
the republican party and of the growing
intense national debate over gun rights
unlike some i didn't disappoint you by
not showing up former president donald
trump the keynote speaker at the
convention knocked republicans who
decided not to be on the nra stage
following the mass shooting in uvalde
alexandria
rubio
alitha
ramirez
while the slaughter from just days
earlier was acknowledged partisanship
was central trump called the latest push
for gun control politically motivated
they want
total gun
confiscation
know that
this would be a first step
once they get the first step they'll
take the second step the third the
fourth and then
you'll have a whole different
look at the second
amendment trump's message was echoed by
many others underscoring how most top
republicans remain in lockstep with the
nra we know that keeping guns away from
citizens who follow the law
does very little to keep them away from
criminals
outside the convention hall activists
and children expressed outrage we're
pleading for help
so did texas democratic leaders
i don't know
that there is compromise with the
leadership of the nra they prioritize
power and profits over lives there were
flickers of hope that some gun control
measure is possible we're just months
ahead of the midterm elections will
washington remain divided and stalled
on gun law i hope not i hope even my
sense of anxiety and my sense of anger
does not counter our responsibility of
working on compromise and getting it
done
though the nra has faced challenges in
recent years gun groups remained
politically powerful spending millions
and later today thousands of attendees
will be here for political organizing
meetings michelle and appears doubling
down bob costa in houston thank you